this is huge huge breaking news ladies
and gentlemen from newsweek.com Alex
Jones warns of possible terrorist
attacks in the US I can't believe it
that's crazy of all the people Alex
Jones saying this I mean if Alex is
saying it you know this this is a
shocking thing for him to say it must be
true yeah well loves him they trust him
implicitly let me just ask this question
first I want to say this yeah Alex is
correct there's there's a fear
considering the the open the forest
border and what's going on with Israel
and and Hamas there could be Terror
attacks but I just why is Newsweek
running a headline Alex Jones warrants
of Terror attacks this is definitely one
journals on their desk who's like I got
to get to my last story of the day
somebody please say something so let me
let me Newsweek has actually been very
friendly to me and I think they've
pretty good of all of the the mainstream
corporate media Outlets I think Newsweek
is the most Libertarian friendly yeah
well they they've got uh uh is is is baa
still there cuz she's fantastic I don't
know they they they've given
they've they've given a lot of push back
to the lies and the manipulations from
the The Establishment narrative they
publish a lot of my op-eds I have a lot
of opsol no I like I'm just wondering
like you know Alex Jones warns of Terror
attacks quite a bit yeah he does you
know I mean like maybe there was
something about this particular terror
attack give any more
details deta let's see yeah they say
that because of hamas's attack on Israel
that uh uh America has the same problem
Hamas le blah blah blah blah blah Jones
without offering evidence told B he
feels it's only a matter of when not if
there's on the US similar to what Israel
experienced I love how they do this
without offering evidence yeah here's my
evidence what was it four Iranians
captured the southern border and 200 or
so people on the terror watch list
that's evidence yeah there have been
multiple arrests of Americans who have
been radicalized in major cities in the
last year I remember one was a white guy
from Maine who took a bus to New York or
and and uh stabbed someone and he said
it was you know he he was Islamic and
this is this is what he had to do for
his whatever right of passage
that doesn't seem like nothing right
this doesn't happen out of nowhere
without evidence would mean he has just
arrived on the planet and he's never
been involved in American Poli too bad
all the US taxpayer dollars went to
build Israel's Iron
Dome we don't have that here we don't
need that we don't even need a wall
because that's how good the Biden
Administration is
fantastic yeah I mean uh I don't think
Israel would exist without US Dollars
obviously that is not my problem yeah
that is so not my problem it's not the
problem of anyone States for us to be
funding any other countries either and
nope and yet they're all like please
more money immediately you know seen
parks and R for the girls like more
money please and they're like just give
her some so she'll go away yeah I wonder
if they would change the way that they
behave if they did not have the United
States
dollar I don't think they would exist
they wouldn't Israel yeah I don't think
they wouldn't exist that without the
Iron Dome they they she would not be
able to live there well okay they've got
it now let's just cut them off you know
yeah but like
Daddy's trust fund well you know get
creative don't they don't they create
tons of pharmaceuticals including
hormones and they do and they also do a
lot of surveillance technology and uh I
think they do a lot of um military Tech
stuff as well they're very smart they
figure it out did you see that story
that was in the new Zeal it says like
I'm trans and I support Palestine but
Israel creates my home that's from 2018
but I'm saying but it was like a like a
Timeless yes a Timeless tale Timeless
tale T is old as time I mean it was a
great uh insight into the the fact that
this has been a long raising tension
within super Progressive communities in
the US right this isn't something that
just I I think that's what bothers me
most about all of this is that it's not
like on October 7th Hamas just attacked
out of nowhere this has been building
for a long time and in fact we know that
because our own political circles are
having trouble reconciling when they
share certain opinions with people but
also disagree on anyone trying to do
trying to just engage Hamas in talks
even if it's not peace talks just hey
there there was the Piza from oh maybe
Jordan is I was thinking about the
Catholic leader that's based the the
patriarch of Jerusalem Saudi Arabia hard
to get them on the phone I think Saudi
Arabia is having a meeting with Hamas
let me check that's good someone needs
to do that keep calling but again like
Hamas would have to be open to it and I
don't know that that's hamas's top
priority now because they are not
motivated for peace because
they're they did reach out they did
Reach Out initially I believe um almost
initially but after that I haven't heard
anything else about it oh okay well the
the the the larger story is that is uh
Israel Israeli and Saudi leaders were
going to be meeting to have peace talks
and then Hamas fired a bunch of rockets
yeah and now it's off and now it's off
yeah now it's off someone needs to be
aggressively trying to talk to these
people I don't even I don't even think
I'd start with calling it a peace talk
but maybe a what the hell talk can we
have a what the hell talk I mean we had
Max Blumenthal here he basically said
that the reason Hamas attacked Israel is
because Israel was having these
normalization conversations and they
want I'm like they're evil yeah that's
Max is Max really knows his stuff he's
very good on foreign policy yeah but
he's you know he's very Pro Palestine
he's outright saying like Hamas engaged
in these these actions targeting
civilians and and and and killing people
because they were trying to stop peace
in the Middle East out of desperation
yeah well because peace in the Middle
East for them is a loss right like they
don't want peace in the Middle East
because they don't want a two State
solution maybe I'm wrong and
misinterpreting this but the the thing
that Israel or other countries might
present as peace is still considered
satisfactory it seems incredibly
disgusting and unsavory and unbelievable
for us to like kind of have to wrestle
with this right now but when you look
back throughout history and you look at
things like the USS Liberty and the
bombing of Pearl Harbor there are things
that are highly suspicious that our
government has had Intelligence on 911
and then maybe it happened anyway and so
there's a real argument as to how much
they knew is not out of the question
that Israel might have known what was
going to happen and allowed it to happen
I don't I don't know for sure that
that's the cas but it's not
inconceivable but I do think it's highly
improbable and I asked Max about it and
Max also disagreed he said that Israel
is uh has this very serious I forgot
what you call a military Doctrine where
they will shoot to kill their own
soldiers if they're being captured by
Hamas that's how much they do not want
Israeli soldiers to be captured by Hamas
oh understand the idea that they would
allow hundreds of civilians and soldiers
to be captured is is unquestionable how
did they miss an attack when they have
such high Sur they the guy who came out
and said something and spoke for Hamas
said that they had only spoken about
between like three or four of the top
individuals within H so like yeah it was
all it was all like super hush on
purpose because they know they can catch
up on them and and not just that a lot
of people are pointing to Egypt having
warned Israel 10 days prior if that's
evidence and it's like dude if someone
comes to you and says hey man something
big might be coming like keep your
security up you'll be like okay does it
mean you know that like a bunch of dudes
are going to break in your garage and
steal your car right no no I I I I think
it's possible I think I think there's a
possibility that Israel there cly
supicious I think it's suspicious and I
think people should be open to it but I
do think there should be evidence before
we make you know sweet it's
substantially less likely the the
argument is that the the political uh
state of Israel has been in disarray
there's been massive conflict and
protests and this this conflict has
resulted in you know Netanyahu getting
people ring around him but I don't agree
with that because if you look at the the
collapse of the peace agreements
Israel's on the verge of making a whole
lot of money and getting a whole lot of
influence in the region if these peace
talks go through it all falls apart
right now yeah I I I think more likely
Hamas caught him off guard they didn't
expect it to happen and they retaliated
and now they've just lost this
tremendous opportunity I mean the idea
that they were going to have economic
normalization was about to make the
region substantially
wealthier gone so you know I think about
it I'm like I don't see the Israeli
leadership as ideological as Hamas
though I do see them as more ideological
than we would expect someone to be yes
more more ideological than we are here
in the United States especially zionists
overt zionists but uh I think for the
average person Money Talks BS walks I
think for Hamas that's not the case I
agree so when it comes to what seems to
make the most sense a lot of very very
wealthy people who are Israeli have lost
a lot of money over this happening and I
really don't see the nepotism and the
elitism allowing something like that to
happen like I I don't see them going and
being like we know this might happen and
all of our most wealthy connected
families are going to lose lots of money
over it I I'm they're probably the phone
calls came in I'm sure billionaires
screaming in faces serious threats I
will end your political career how did
you miss this I really doubt some
billionaire was like well I'm going to
lose 100 million tomorrow but it's okay
I don't I don't think so everyone is
rallying around Netanyahu sure I mean
that that that happens there are a lot
of people uh that I've talked to about
it where they're like you know I I know
someone who's got like a wealthy family
that they're Israeli but they live in
New York or whatever I'm like I don't
think these people wanted to lose
massive portions of their net worth no
certainly not yeah I don't think they're
that ideological Netanyahu may may may
see some benefit from this but I
ultimately think it's going to cost him
substantially politically like at the
very least he's going to owe a lot of
people a lot of stuff and not just him a
lot of people in the Israeli government
who missed this do we know how long he's
been in office now oh man it's like 16
years or something a really long time he
was out of office for a minute there
right he like got reelected right yeah I
can look it up 16
years from 96 to 99 and from from 2009
to
2021 yeah for a long
time yeah so hard to get rid of a
wartime
president yeah and then and they're in
war quite a bit Minister mhm yeah mhm
but I guess the bigger question is was
Alex Jones right I guess find we have a
jar here that says he is all the time
yeah yeah it's got a lot of money in it
yeah jar relative to you know a really
big jar uh it is there's also a lot of
fake money I was to say I think most of
that money is fake but there some real
money in there is there some real money
in there there's like prop stacks of
$100 bills in there I tell people cuz
like uh on on the show on on PCC we have
the the money guns I was like we going
to put like five real $100 bills in
there and say anybody wants to help
clean it up like you can keep the real
100 if you find it you you should get an
Alex Jones was right jar and put it on
the table and then when the money go and
goes off you're like trying to
catch trying to catch the money there
you go I mean I think this statement is
not specific enough to say whether he's
right or wrong because probably it will
happen um it's no shame shade to
Newsweek journalists I also sometimes
struggle to get a story out at the end
of the day but I would like to have seen
more specific I just thought it was
funny they would also deny the evidence
anyways but it's just Ronda santis said
the same thing and uh so you know Kevin
MTH said the same thing it's not
surprising that Alex Jones is now saying
the same thing when uh when Alex
predicted the U uh the Russian invasion
in Ukraine everybody started losing it
being like dude he several months ago he
warned this was going to happen like
almost specifically in over like to the
te and uh you know I was talking to
about it because we had that event and
he was like he's like Tim I just read
the news like I I don't know he was he
was basically like everyone was
surprised he got it right he was like
there's a bunch of news stories about it
like he wasn't doing anything but it's
because there's a caricature that he's
just this loud dumb guy who screams on
YouTube or whatever like a lot of people
mainstream and left leaning don't know
anything about him so the fact that he
would get anything right is just
shocking to him because they only know
him as this guy who gets everything
wrong and he says these crazy things
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net
for uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time